welcome to this video playing vegan ito
bigger neato from Spain yeah there's
some guy constantly asking why I'm
losing so often against the spanish
players and I think I looked quite sure
that I'll do so often against them but
it is one simple fact that there are
simply very very gather many spanish
players are here spain seems to be M yes
Ben has many many players are simply so
you are you bound to lose a head against
them if you play many games I'm not
quite sure I really have a totally bad
score against them um yeah and I very
much enjoyed playing this tournament on
my your cow and now in which is Spain
after all very young very nice to be
down um I didn't play why I played a
couple of spanish players there and that
didn't lose a game only lost against the
Ukrainian player okay so I've got a
pretty good Kings Indian here from prom
ef5 yes the night on the sixth of course
is a is a fantastic piece it just takes
be five at xe4 blocks d5 fantastic piece
I'm trying to activate the bishop as
well to III would be great III to deform
you're still allowed to dream what your
pieces can do okay can try to flee
easily guy nothin maybe you cannot so
easily cover it how does he cover it I
thought at first like Quincy three but I
can take you for ya know I can give that
should I check it I will
yeah interesting i can take i can play a
for ya f-4s is tempting up because queen
h4 g5 Luke f6 that sets up and attack
really quickly probably probably this is
fine yeah he can play night see tool I
wonder if I should yeah I do that come
on let's not think about it too long
allowing a retreat to see five so that
so that actually keep the bishop on this
great diagonal online situ I can go to
see five and there it would stay cannot
easily be driven away night be 43 but
then i go to d4 I just want to keep the
bishop and get in this attacking idea
whether this g5g hi you gave six of
course threatening the very yeah the
very crude Queen H to check made once
the rook is on f6
yeah but it will get dangerous i mean i
have two rooks that can join this attack
very tricky to play this position the
bishop on d3 is simply not defending at
all and the bishop at the night on c2
it's just them yeah just the spectator
as well he might play kiwi new one mmm
okay well then I seconds the Queen away
but hmm er not so clear how to how to
play this do I need age 5 and g4 and
maybe i do if i go g4 here hmm i can
take what they have pawned there is no
no big threat down
I actually I need the rook on h4 and
it's more important than the Queen being
now look H for Queen h6 really going to
what is why is it going to see sexy
maybe but I can always play just rope
yet if I really really feel the need to
cover it other than that the knight on
c6 is not doing much maybe this isn't
some right ready it looks fantastic with
this bishop on c5 but it's not clear how
how I'm really winning this this thing
how I'm breaking through
I need rooks this is say this much is
clear maybe he can play knight c6 and
yeah yeah and cling to see 3 this is
type of stuff maybe
Quincy three are not quite sure what I'm
doing against this I can go Queen d7
threatening rook h3 but hmm it's so it's
just teenage to Evan I am missing an
important resource resource all the time
with G for FTX night before this I
should have done some time ago already
Wow
should I still do it yeah come on this I
should have done a long time ago when
night g3 was still a big Fork yeah and
he has hot lights you find actually but
if I've hangs I can go to g3 but this
does not relieve not really help much
I can probably just take on e5 and it's
not clear what all this is is leading to
time morning I really don't see see
something else anything else would be
correct yeah this is just not good job I
should have played g4 far far earlier
far earlier then then it would have been
very dangerous for him i'm pretty sure
i'm hoping for the capture so that i can
take with check getting all my pieces
active and I'm threatening and not
really look at the look aged 3 i'm
threatening look aged three actually and
Knight f3 is taking a long time check
maybe here in this is simply not good
threatening 94 yeah I have I have some
activity it's not it's not not
completely easy to play for Jack and now
i'm ok again but it's a very very shaky
business how do i play that i won't want
to keep the porn try to put the bishop
here and then only then take a you come
at this
I can go to the three back with the
knife g5 okay not one to one to fork
Knight f6 guide for Fitz I'm telling our
time here this wasn't really great I
mean it was ok this position really but
I missed a very important resource here
I think of compensation but but probably
not more than that it looks so it looks
very dangerous but what I completely
invest was ignoring no not at the moment
um what I was completely ignoring and
then besides many things that were
possible before hear this this G 4 I
mean but I couldn't play it before right
really and not really there one there
wasn't a possible it wasn't a spot where
I could have done that yeah maybe here I
have something I can go to g3 of course
but it didn't feel right to me to trade
this off just in terms of practical
chances maybe it's still better I didn't
want to do that check this this type of
position as white is very very nicely
coordinated and the night is a source
for counter play objectively speaking
and probably much worse yeah the
computer gives white white a flat-out
win
hmm yeah it's it's just not good it's
just not good he am threatening Luke age
3m this is a slight hope but he can just
play how he did but he must go to 22 g
one uh yeah I could have taken already I
didn't see that mmm good this is strong
check this is strong check yeah this is
also ok yeah so what what what does this
mean exactly I'm in here check this
means that this is a bad idea yeah of
course I can take maybe this is just bet
I am opening it up directly yeah this is
a direct win according to the comp okay
yeah yeah it's simply better right
because his coordination is also not
really great if we look at this check
then he am checking here and I still
have those attacking chance assume he
cannot play this cell because of c4 and
this is totally totally winning yeah
this was much better it looked so it
looked so attractive took 22 to get the
king on each one dreaming of this
sacrifices on h2 but probably it's not
not right and here i have bishop t4
actually so night see to Bishop b2 yeah
the tough tough can do many things in
this position ok thanks for watching